let's talk about the big trauma that
energizes your book and this is your
death of mother the death of your mother
in her late 50s from how do you
pronounce it cardiac amyloidosis okay
what is that super rare disease your
body creates a protein your liver can't
break down uh it builds up on your
organs it mostly affects black men so my
mom's a girl and like I'm not mixed if
you can't tell like she's white
um so it was really unexpected she died
at 57 just about three weeks after she
was formally diagnosed and I obviously
it was awful and traumatic and I felt
that in addition to it being devastating
it was also isolating because I could
tell
how scared people were to talk to me
after that happened because they were so
scared of saying the wrong thing and
it's like I felt like I could have a
real conversation with anybody and it's
some of the people would say would
be so like oh at least you got to say
goodbye and it's just like bro like what
do you say to people who died in car
accidents you know like oh at least she
wasn't like torn limb from limb in front
of you and sat on fire like like you're
not like you're not helping you know and
then also I felt that joking about it
was helpful my mom was joking about
herself dying as she was dying and I
felt like people and I didn't feel like
that people would actually on me
for dealing with that it that way uh the
first Mother's Day after my mom died you
know I I was sad but I felt bad I want
to say anything I was like oh the second
one I'm still sad because it's like you
see all the Instagram all the people are
like out to brunch with like you can
only do that with like living people and
I posted a picture of my laundry basket
a bottle of tide and I was like Mom's
Dad gonna do some laundry because I
laughed you know felt a little better
people were on me for that
they're like this is offensive this is
disrespectful i'm like
because yeah you didn't know her like I
came out of her body you don't even like
you don't know me at all or her so I I
so I think that you're just giving
decorum for its own sake a higher
purpose than it deserves and that's what
I mean by you're not you're you're
actually hurting the people who you're
trying to help the standards of speech
are supposed to be put into place to
protect people like me who are going
through it but they actually ended up
hurting people like me do you think it
would have been worse if she had died in
a car accident what would people have
said they'd have been like well they'd
probably last joke you know what they've
been like at least not to see her suffer
you know it's like dude just be like
this sucks you know you rode uh in in
your book I was able to manage my misery
because I was doing comedy
um and you you talk about how the harder
something is to talk about the funnier
it you should be about it um you also
Marshal some you know psychology studies
and things like that to talk about the
healing power may be a little too
woo-woo but like you know that this is
actually cathartic and helpful can you
discuss that a little bit absolutely and
I'm unfortunately I have no beliefs like
I'm not I mean in terms of religion
right like I'm not I'm not one of those
people that's not a Christian but then
replace it with astrology like I I don't
have like I'm just you know I'm like you
were raised cap I was raised so Catholic
and I read about that in my last book I
am not a Catholic anymore on my last
chapter rather but it's you know I write
about how comedy is my religion actually
in the last chapter because it provides
a lot of the same things physically
right like the these chemicals that are
released the feel-good chemicals in your
body that can be healing
literally it can help your immune system
um and then the way that it can bring
people together it actually is healing
in the physical sense and not just the
emotional sense and there's proof of
that that even people who are terminally
ill they'll they say that talking about
in a funny way they rate that higher
than talking about in a solemn way but
people still say you can't do that
except for you know the people actually
going through it and the people who
study those people yeah are do you think
uh people are starting to come around to
your point of view or is that just it
really is never going to win the day you
know I I'm very extreme with it and if
you've read the book so Guy Benson from
Fox he interviewed me he had a uh about
that he's a laugh Riot yeah he actually
he can be his husband's much funnier
um but he well that's because his
husband's dying we're not supposed to
tell where that's secret don't uh he was
he said cat some of this stuff
uh especially chapter five I don't know
if you guys read chapter five an
emergency bowel surgery had a bag
for five weeks uh the uh title of the
chapter is bag I had it yeah and I
Had It reversed at the beginning of
January and then I had complications
where blood was gushing out of my ass so
bad that I needed a transfusion and this
was on January 6th wow like that one and
but that's an Insurrection but yeah
here's
most pain
and hilarious right like I like I mean I
I forever I didn't want to talk about it
though because I don't want people to be
like oh like no I'm not okay if it's a
gaping wound in my stomach I can't even
see my belly button like I'm not okay
I'm not okay bro no but every time I had
to watch like different politicians cry
on TV about I was like I bet you my
January 6th was worse than yours
but he asked me why do you share and if
you think that was graphic I get very
detailed about the blood go she got in
the ass and the bag and all the
mechanics of that it's quite informative
and he said why did you like why did you
get into that much detail and I said
because I didn't want to say you can
joke about everything and no subject off
limits and then make something off
limits where I could have been open
about it instead